the 35th annual national football league  selection meeting is now in session  first choice first round pittsburgh  steelers  steelers select  terry bradshaw quarterback louisiana  tech  where'd that come from  [Laughter]  i was  how did i get to be the first pick in  the draft i don't want to be the first  pick of the  trip looking back on it now i'm like oh  that's kind of cool but  really truthfully i shouldn't have been  i went to this small school and  so immature so much to learn in high  school only started one year in college  only two  so i can be patient  why would anybody pick me in the first  round  i don't know why chuck noll drafted me  you